the following graph shows a proportional
relationship
what is the constant of proportionality
between y and x in the graph
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right now let's do this together and
let's remind ourselves what a constant
of proportionality even is
if we know that there is a proportional
relationship between y and x then there
will be a constant of proportionality
between these variables and what this is
is it is a number that i would have to
multiply x by to get 2y
so i could make a little table here as
we often do when we describe
proportional relationships x and y
we know that when x is 0 y is 0
but if i multiply 0 by anything i'm
going to get 0
but then when x is 1 what is y when x is
1 y is 3 they mark it right over there
when x is 2
what is y x is 2
we see that y
is 6.
so our constant of proportionality is
what are we multiplying x by to get to y
well let's see to go from one to three i
have to multiply by three to go from two
to six i have to multiply by three
another way to think about it is we
could write the equation y is equal to
something times x the number that we
multiply x by to get y is our constant
of proportionality and we've seen in all
of these situations this should be true
for any point on this line you give the
x you multiply it by 3 you get your y so
the relationship here is y
is equal to 3x so 3 is our constant of
proportionality